magnifying lenses like the ones in
today's microscopes gave us of course
our first glimpses into the world of the
micro cosmos but it was not the first
time people had guessed that there might
be more to the world than met our eyes
particularly regarding illness Marcus
Terentius Varro a Roman scholar in 30 BC
wrote about the need to be cautious
around swamps quote because they're bred
certain animal cool a which cannot be
seen by the eyes which float in the air
and enter the body through the mouth and
nose and their cause serious diseases
Marcus
thus managed to guess at a reality that
it would take thousands more years and a
great deal of debate to confirm even now
when it comes to human understanding of
our unseen neighbors our focus is almost
always driven by negative interactions
our most vivid collective encounters are
also some of the most unpleasant the
sneezing the coughing the upset stomachs
the death evidence of an apparent
tension between our bodies in the
microbial world
this strange little guy is a parasitic
flatworm but for now it's in it's sir
carry alarm a larva in search of a host
preferably animals like duck geese and
raccoons where it can feed on their
blood and then mature into adulthood and
release eggs through the infected
animals waste from the eggs will emerge
a ciliated larva that will seek out
particular species of aquatic snails to
serve as an intermediate host as they
develop into their serial stage and
complete the cycle for all the hosts
this parasite will go through it turns
out that we humans are not a
particularly great one they can infect
us and when they do they will burrow
into the skin and create little bumps
inciting an allergic reaction that
produces a rash formerly known as circ
aerial dermatitis but it's more
frequently known as swimmers itch thanks
to its aquatic origin but for the circ
area a real challenge is that we just
aren't the right bodies to house its
development and to adulthood and instead
it will die
the word germs might be the very first
term many of us learn to describe
microbes an easy word that warns us from
an early age that there are things we
cannot see that nonetheless we must
watch out for and with medical necessity
often shaping the direction of
scientific research their potential
danger is further emphasized because it
has inspired and shaped so much of our
understanding of microorganisms and so
we know a great deal about the microbes
that can hurt us and next to nothing
about the ones that can't but necessity
is now driving us to better grasp the
complexity of microbes in relation to us
the idea that they are only ever enemies
is contradicted by our developing
understanding of the organisms that live
in and on us not just as freeloaders but
potentially as part of our bodies
mechanics words like microbiome and
probiotic are now part of our
understanding of the world and also part
of active research though a far smaller
part and research focused on pathogens
but and stop me if you've heard this
before it turns out the world is bigger
than humans and beyond our own
perimeters there's the importance of
microbes to the world around us what is
known about that world is a tiny
percentage of what there is to know
[Music]
now as we delve more into the balance
between microbes that both help and harm
we do want to remind you that however
harmless or beautiful or fascinating the
microbes we show you here are you should
still wash your hands and get your shots
and having done away with that though
let's remind you that most microbes
cannot hurt you while it would be
challenging to calculate the exact
percentage of microbial species out
there that are pathogenic and could
potentially make us sick estimates put
it somewhere at less than 1% figuring
out what the bacteria in our samples lie
in that slim percentage would require
isolating and growing them up in
cultures so that we can sequence and
properly identify them but we just take
the safe route and you know we don't
drink the pond water bacterial species
do run a range as well giving us
everything from cheese to tetanus for us
though their presence helps sustain the
many bacteria eaters we feature and we
keep them fed on droplets of milk water
from boiled hay cooked rice or even
liquid plant fertilizer now nematodes on
the other hand might seem like a more
clear-cut danger more commonly known as
round worms they are plentiful with
estimates counting them at around 60
billion nematodes for every person on
earth and around 40,000 species in total
but it's a select few of those species
that are particularly notorious for
humans able to enter humans as eggs and
contaminated food or as larvae that can
penetrate the skin depending on the
species so it's understandable if you
respond to the image of a nematode with
some revulsion
but the vastness of them means that
their impact is so much more complex
when you examine them across their
different intersections with life from
ecosystems where they can move other
microbes around the soil and cycle
nutrients like nitrogen to
agriculture where some nematode species
maybe pests while others are helpful
controls of insect populations but these
complications aren't always strictly
about pathogens we featured Euglena here
before their twisty bodies both
fascinating and seemingly harmless but
in 2002 21,000 striped bass died in a
facility in North Carolina the culprit a
balloon of euglena sanguine a which
released a toxin called euglena faison
that is similar in structure to fire ant
venom and yet this danger poses a
potential as well as scientists study
the use of Euglena facin to fight cancer
and unlike nematodes which we decidedly
do not want to ingest there is some
culinary promise for Euglena like
Euglena grassless which for all of its
small size manages to pack in large
amounts of proteins and vitamins there's
an underlying question in this video
about all these microbes we've seen are
they good or bad or neither the answer
of course varies we're still grasping
the extent of what it means to share a
world with organisms that we weren't
able to even see until a few centuries
ago dealing not only with the
consequences of their existence but also
of our own response to what we've
learned understanding bacteria and other
microbes for example that helped us
usher in the modern era of antibiotics
which has saved so many lives but
antibiotic overuse has also led to the
growing threat of antibiotic resistant
bacteria we can't not try to fight
disease or find uses from microbes just
as we can't not interact with the world
around us the challenge then of making
use of our knowledge responsibly of
categorizing good and
and whether at the scale of a microbe or
much much larger hinges on our ability
to identify our place among all of this
to better understand the complexities of
the good and bad of our own actions
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us and thank you of
course to all of the people who support
this channel at patreon.com slash and
journey to micro if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes James
check out Jam and germ on Instagram and
if you want to subscribe to this channel
you should do that
[Music]